looking at spending an awful long time
in prison now isn't he
well we don't know i mean it depends if
the extradition is uh successful if it
is then it could be a life imprisonment
yes
okay go on
yeah one should add that he's actually
uh not had any liberty for about 10
years now so
um you know he has certainly suffered um
and you know the united nations working
group on arbitrage detention
did determine that he was arbitrarily
detained so he has had 10 years so far
of uh of of a compromised freedom
well that was arbitrarily dismissed of
course by the british
government they didn't appreciate that
at all
they didn't but they should have i would
argue i mean because um you know
the the the un is the highest authority
um on this one so
you know in the world so you know
perhaps the decision should have been
listened to
yeah uh of course he did uh choose to
skip bail which is an offense here
in the united kingdom for which he has
been found guilty this afternoon
yes and he received um uh diplomatic
asylum which has been revoked
probably illegally i understand um by
the ecuadorians
okay so you think that it was acceptable
for him to
have skipped bail even though the
charges that he was facing at that
potential charges he was facing at that
time
were in relation to serious sexual
offences in sweden
and nothing to do with wikileaks um or
otherwise in the united states
that's just simply not true um he he was
very clear
many journalists wouldn't accept it that
he was going there to escape exactly
what has now happened to him
um he claimed asylum he received asylum
um and um he was saying it's because he
didn't want to be
ex right to the states and that's
exactly what appears to be happening now
um the swedish matteo
by the way and please note that the um
crown prosecution servant
were revealed to have um encouraged this
swedish prosecutor not to actually
prosecute he was never charged with
anything
essentially you had our prosecution
service
and the swedish prosecution prosecution
service not prosecuting so i
i think this funny business has been
going on what do you say ali
uh what are you suggesting what are you
alleging what i'm suggesting is that
like there wasn't as
i i mean sorry i've been quite clear i
was being very clear that
um you know if if the prosecutors aren't
prepared to prosecute
why would we take that prosecution or
you know the the the allegations
seriously
and the the swedish prosecutor wouldn't
come to london to interview julian which
they they're quite happy
no no and in addition to that there was
no desire to prosecute um
and uh the al la republica a an italian
newspaper
um you can look this up um did a freedom
of information
uh request in sweden and and was able to
retrieve
emails that the crown prosecution
service had destroyed um
which discouraged the swedes from
anyway they've dropped that i mean
what's happening now is is nothing to do
with sweden
okay so it is uh you are suggesting
everything to do
with wikileaks in the united states why
do you feel that he doesn't have a case
to answer
no i i'm not saying that there's no what
do you mean about the swedish stuff or
the american stuff
no the american stuff well i mean you
know
yes i mean there's an indictment that
was published um
and they wish to extradite him now now
whether you know i'm not sure that
people in this country um are
necessarily happy to see an extradition
on this basis
um you know it looks this is really uh
you know spiteful self-interested
politics
i mean yes we're we should be fine um
extraditing murders and
and people who are bank robbers and
people like that but this is about
julian revealing the truth about a a
foreign government
um uncomfortable truth about the foreign
government this is a completely
different thing
uh this is really a vendetta it's
revenge by the americans on julian they
want to set an example of him and you
know we all really know that
but the allegation is not about
publishing
uh these um these wikileaks so is it
it's more
uh to do with um conspiracy
with chelsea manning then bradley
manning
to commit computer intrusion to hack
government servers is that not your
understanding
um i think what they have done and that
is what it what it reads like and
they've been struggling to find
something they can get him on
but it's it's it's not really to do
about that is to set an example of him
um you know what the russians do is they
um they kill people in salisbury
and what the americans want to do in
this instance to discourage other people
from
revealing information that's
uncomfortable to them the truth
um and this is what they do they want to
put him in jail for the rest of his life
yeah it might be uncomfortable but it's
potentially also illegal if he did
conspire to commit computer intrusion to
hack government servers that's
illegal they will they will they will
have to prove that
um but i've just said i don't believe
that's what it is i have to prove it in
a court of law
uh and in order to do that he needs to
face those allegations doesn't he
um no i don't believe so i don't think
we should be so gullible
um you know look the reason people like
me stand behind julian assange is
because at the heart of it wikileaks was
a project that says in a free democracy
that people have the right information
about their ruling elite acts and behave
you know julian threatened the most
powerful people in the world with
exposure um
ordinary people who who thanks to julian
and wikileaks ordinary people now
understand a lot more about the cynicism
but it's about how you access that
information surely
all right well look this this thing goes
back to the afghan war logs and the
diplomatic cables
um eight years ago eight to ten years
ago um
and now it's quite clear that while this
has been going on um obama
thought okay this problem doesn't stand
up he's a publisher
um and decided not to do it and let
chelsea manning out of jail after four
years
chelsea manning is now back in jail
clearly what trump wants is sort of
a trophy show trial before 2020 election
uh you can't hack government uh
service or with someone else to commit
uh hang on this is our government finish
my question and then you can answer it
[Music]
is that possible you cannot it is
illegal thank you it is illegal to hack
government servers
uh or uh to conspire with someone else
in order to do that that is illegal
so um that is the charge that is likely
to be
about something that needs to be tested
in the courts frankly and
you sound like the american government
is our government it's not our
government
um this is a foreign government it's a
foreign state i mean if it was russia if
if julian had um maybe not russia if it
doesn't matter it's america it's a
foreign state
we seem to act as if america has the
right to pull people from our country
just because they don't like them and
you're talking uh if there's a search
they have they have they have an ability
to ask
our government to extradite somebody
that they feel needs to answer
these allegations in a court of law
that's what america
is asking would we pull somebody out of
an embassy who's got asylum for the
russian government
or just the american government that
surely that's that's that's a nebulous
argument
why because the american government have
asked us specifically whether we can
uh provide uh information from provide
this gentleman to
to them via video link to see whether
there is a case
to answer why is that not acceptable
um it's not acceptable because we know
what's going on here
it's not acceptable because we wouldn't
do it for other governments it's you
know
we have extremely weak extradition laws
with with the united states of america
um and uh you know julian has been in
all the supernatural bodies for example
the
um intra-american um court of human
rights as judge in his favor that he was
in a site you know he
received asylum he'd have been entitled
to it um ecuador has been pressured by
the americans
and us um and uh you know simply to
do america's bidding um and i'm look i
think
you know julian is somebody who has
brought forward um
old debate about transparency in a way
that was incredibly important
and and i i know he needs to be able to
participate in that
um and just this is just bullying this
is sort of victimizing him this is uh
you know taking out on julian
um and because he's threatened the most
powerful people with the world
with it with exposure he must not be
extradited in the united states to be
absolutely scandalous to that